welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and as it becomes more evident how
the mcu that we have known has been
crafted and manipulated by kang the
conqueror for the avengers the question
now becomes how do we kill this guy not
that i ever want to say goodbye to what
jonathan majors is bringing to the mcu
i'd honestly be okay with giving this
guy the mic to monologue while he
munches on fruit in every movie from now
till the end of time thing about kang is
he actually could do that add your
apples because no matter how many times
you defeat this guy he always comes back
as some variant 3 000 moves ahead of you
so the question of how to kill gang
isn't just a plot premise for conflicts
like quantomania kang dynasty and secret
wars it's really a question that's
fundamental to kang's core identity and
how complicated and formidable of a
threat he will beat the marvel heroes so
let's break down kang's history in the
marvel comics the fights he's been part
of how he's been defeated each time and
how ultimately marvel studios is
probably gonna do him in kang the
conqueror was first introduced in
avengers number 8 1964 but the character
of pharaoh ramatuch was actually
introduced earlier in the fantastic four
number 19 in 1963. stan lee and jack
kirby initially conceived of kang as a
future time displaced descendant of
doctor doom throughout the 60s like in
avengers number 23 we learned about
gang's exploits to woo ravana rinse
layer that actually may be why rent
slayer's hunter designation in loki was
a23 in 1974 avengers number 128 that was
the celestial madonna storyline in which
a variant kang sought three powerful
females as possible mothers to a
destined all-powerful offspring he
selected the scar of the witch mantis
and act of the harkness spoiler warning
and ends up being mantis this is also
the storyline that merged the kang
identity with the pharaoh rama tut
identity in this storyline though
another version of kang teams up with
the avengers who's led by the swordsman
yup
this guy from the mcu and having one
kang on their side ends up being how
they're able to defeat this rama tut so
haha oh one way to kill kang throw
another gang at him but shortly after
this 1974 comic the kang identity would
also be merged with the avengers villain
of immortus now the term kang dynasty
actually came up in 1986 with avengers
number 268 yes the same number of the
avengers compound watch in hawkeye i'm
telling you they have been setting all
this up and in this storyline the
avengers along with neymar captain
marvel hercules fight the council of
kangs and kang's various minions as they
get in and out of limbo really the event
best known as kang dynasty unfolded in
2001 2002 when kang split from his
mortise identity and set his sights on
conquering earth and setting up a
dynasty with countless sons named marcus
in a way it's kind of similar to what
ego was doing hooking up with anybody he
could to produce a viable offspring kang
approaches the u.n to warn them of
various future apocalyptic events he
offers them to surrender to him but of
course they refuse a big fight breaks
out he overtakes the sentinel that they
send to his orbital base and he uses
these sentinels to wipe out washington
dc the avengers whom he thought he'd
banish off world are able to mount a
comeback and defeat him leaving him
stranded and alone with his son now
disney plus moon knight referenced kang
a few times including a qr code taking
us to a 2019 moon knight acts of evil
comic in which moon knight races through
time against kang to acquire three
totems of konchu the way moon knight's
able to defeat kang is by using several
alternate versions of moon knight so
another tactic to defeating kang double
and triple up against him using your own
variants in fact you could argue that's
what loki and sophie did but i think
this specific citation in the moon night
final episode tells us that marvel
studios might be pulling from the more
modern era of kang and i think the
likeliest option for the events of kang
dynasty would be the 2017 adventures
unleashed kang war storyline written by
mark wade this storyline really is most
logically consistent with the rules of
the multiverse laid out by jonathan
hickman's fantastic war logic through
the time runs out storyline in the 2015
secret war storylines which of course is
what avengers secret wars is probably
gonna be adapting based on the way reed
richards described the multiverse and
incursions and multiverse of madness
that just really seems to be the
direction marvel studios is going in
general in this kang war storyline mark
wade established that every form of kang
that had been introduced up until that
point in marvel comics were the results
of one origin kang and the final kang
known as kang prime kang prime sits at
the end of time but when this guy
started each time he went back in time
he created a new branch timeline in a
new version of kang that resulted from
it that's how he got pharaoh rama tut
that's how we got immortus that's how we
got scarlet centurion another form of
kang et cetera et cetera but rama tut as
the first instance was what initially
corrupted nathaniel richards with a lust
for power actually the artwork of rama
tut from this 2017 storyline was the
artwork that the moon knight team
deliberately chose to form their kang
easter egg so i'm telling you you gotta
read this comic story line i think it's
gonna be important if you've watched a
lot of our channel you've definitely
heard us mention helix mattresses which
is where we all go to sleep after
wearing ourselves out making videos all
day and where we dream up our most
outlandish theories we love helix and
that's why we are so stoked to hear that
the same people who make helix
mattresses are leaving the bedroom and
entering our waking life with a new
company called all form which makes
custom sofas all four makes it easy to
pick a sofa that's the right size color
shape and fabric for you and your home
they've got everything from arm chairs
and love seats to eight-seat sectionals
your custom sofa ships to your home for
free in just three to seven days and you
can assemble it yourself easily once it
arrives new rockstars editor and
producer john got a brown leather
armchair and ottoman from all form and
absolutely loves them that's a nice
chair
he dreams about live editing the break
room while getting in a quick nap in his
comfy chair they have a 100 day trial so
you can get more than three months to
make sure that you love it and if you
don't they will pick it up for you and
you will get a full refund keep your
sofa and you'll get a forever warranty
literally forever we love the all form
furniture that we've gotten and we think
you will too to find your perfect sofa
check out allform.com new rockstars all
form is offering 20 off all orders for
our audience at allforum.com new
rockstars but kang prime established in
the distant time stream caches of
financial resources and weaponry
literally societies whose only function
was to mine minerals zedkan could use
his money and build weaponry that he
could use to conquer places and in the
distant future kang prime just feeds on
all of it but in the present our boy
vision is calculating to try to find a
way to eradicate kang from the time
stream because he recognizes every time
we kill this guy he keeps coming back so
what do we do and vision concludes that
they must get to the future nathaniel
richards when he is a babe basically the
hitler maybe argument but if hitler was
a a future warlord this obviously sets
up a nasty debate between vision and the
other avengers at the time now previous
to this hickman's timeline logic
established that changes to the timeline
in the past have a delayed effect so
kang prime has a bit of time to get
ahead of this so he to counter the
avengers goes back to target the baby
forms of all the avengers that are
trying to kill his baby form all the
avengers get pruned to limbo except
hercules because none of them really
know how hercules is born hercules at
this point acquires an amulet that
anchors him in the present he's able to
use this to empower the rest of the
avengers to confront all the versions of
kangs the avengers versus all the kang
variants vision successfully targets
kang prime's resource caches cutting off
kang prime at the knees vision ends up
deciding to send wasp to return baby
kang back to his point of origin and
restore everything and hank pym is able
to save the day by trapping kang prime
in a mortise and a future version of
kang merged with doctor doom in a kind
of pocket reality and all that is really
left at the end of this fight is baby
kang looked over by some vietnamese
priests his future unknown and i think
the films are pulling from this story
not just because their connection to
secret wars and the time runs out era
but the avenger lineup and the story
actually pretty closely matches what we
currently have in the mcu sam wilson
hercules mighty thor spider-man wasp
vision in the storyline could be swapped
out by doctor strange a guy who in the
mcu loves to do grand calculus of the
multiverse in his head to see future
events i have theorized that the film
avengers kang dynasty will be the
avengers in the fantastic four in this
kind of time war against the full
council of kangs and whenever you're
structuring an epic story like this one
person versus group or group versus
group it helps to set up multiple tasks
in a kind of numbered list like think
about it the six infinity stones of
thanos the five names on the bride's
death list and kill build the six
horcruxes of harry potter and voldemort
the seven evil ex-boyfriends that scott
pilgrim has to defeat and if we look at
it this way i think kang dynasty will be
these seven alternate forms of kang in
their line of succession he who remains
was the first the king at the very end
of the line and thus would be least
worried about by the others and then
after that might be the kang and
quantomania then the kang and loki
season two then pharaoh ramatet then
scarlet centurion then immortus each of
these increasingly more dangerous than
the last as we head up the line toward
the kang on the throne kang prime each
of these will have to be defeated one by
one maybe turning some against the other
through unique tasks specific to this
particular version of kang and the
avenger who confronts them that avenger
using some multiversal mechanics to undo
them for example the moon knight acts of
evil task with rama tut so moon knight
might be important warrior in that
particular task if they bring in the
celestial madonna storyline mantis could
be important to defeating another kang
maybe another task will follow iron lads
arc in the comics where iron lad has to
sacrifice himself to allow himself to
become kang in the future in order to
avert a paradox i think the kang dynasty
film will likely end with the avengers
failing to defeat the final kang kang
prime who could be revealed as a future
descendant of doctor doom getting back
to what jack kirby and stanley initially
attended for the character after all in
the comics it was doom's time portal
where nathaniel richards derived his
time travel technology and the
multiverse madness producers confirmed
the 838 reed richards portal was based
on doom's time portal so that would set
up kang prime to play the role of god
emperor doom and reassemble all the
avengers and fantastic four and x-men in
his battle world sandbox and secret wars
so getting back to the question how does
one kill kang the answer the same way
the kang war storyline does you don't
the very act of trying to kill a kang or
trying to prune them is what like the
head of a hydra what just leads to more
kang sprouting so i think the multiverse
saga will end with kang being left in
the form of an innocent youth the task
ahead need to keep that youth on the
right path so that he never seeks to be
a conqueror i mean my friends isn't that
the ultimate mission of life to strive
every day to make sure our descendants
do better than we did let me know your
thoughts on this theory and follow me on
instagram and twitter at boss follow new
rockstars subscribe to new rockstars for
more analysis of everything you love
thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you